Hello.
And welcome back to the Rawkode Academy. Today,
we are following on with our Fermion Spin
course.
And in particular, we're following on from the
last video where I showed you how
to deploy the Fermion platform
so that you can actually run your own
spin applications
on your own cloud provider or hardware provider
of choice.
Today will be a a quick episode where
we take a look at an evolution of
that architecture.
So in the first one, we jumped through
the Fermion installer repository
where we used the Civo cloud provider,
so I contributed by SIAM, to spin up
some Civo virtual machines
and deploy everything with cloud in it.
Well, I've actually contributed or at least it's
in a PR just now to the installer
repository
with some code that allows you to do
this with Equinix metal.
Now why would I do this with Equinix
metal?
Well,
one bare metal is more fun.
I always like working with loads of loads
of cores and loads of RAM and super
chunky gigabit network cards. But
they also expose BGP to you,
which means we can do some really sophisticated
routing
at the network level when we have more
than one family on platform.
Now you've probably seen me chat about BGP
before. I'm a huge fan. I think it
opens up infinite scale. Well, you know, that's
a scary word to use, but it opens
up certainly different
scaling avenues
where you can provide low latency applications to
your customers.
So we're gonna take a look at that
today in the context of Fairmain's platform
and web assembly.
So
let's share my screen.
Hopefully,
here we go.
And this read me,
and
you can find this and currently a pull
request
at github.com/firmion/installer.
This is the Equinix metal directory, which has
a read me. It tells you everything that
you need to know.
Essentially, you need an Equinix metal account, and
you need a user level API key.
We need a user level API key because
project level API keys cannot change the BGP
configuration.
So you all have to use a user
level key.
And you must have BGP enabled for your
project. So what does that look like? Well,
if you come to project settings,
nope.
If you go to networking BGP
and I'll zoom in.
You can see here this is already enabled
like so. If you don't see this, what
you're actually going to see is a big
blue button that says, hey, do you want
to enable BGP on this project? So as
long as you see something that looks like
this, you are good to go.
Now you need to export your API key
as metal off token
as we can see here.
This uses a bunch of defaults as part
of the automation. One is gonna create your
instances and call them fermion at least as
a prefix dependent on the metro that we
deploy to and it's going to use a
c d small x 86 instance.
This is gonna cost you about $1 per
hour. So remember to shut it down if
you're only playing around and not deploying this
to production.
We also allocate one global IP address which
allows us to use BGP.
Next, all we need to do is CDN
to the Terraform directory,
run Terraform and Terraform
apply.
Now, let's see if it's that easy.
As you can see, I'm in the Equinix
manual slash Terraform directory
and I'm going to run terraform edit.
This has been done plenty of times while
I was testing those pull request.
So this should be nice and fast. If
I just finished, I'm a meeting a little
bit longer for you as it pulls down
the providers.
And I see Russell has joined us in
the chat. Hey, Russell. I was a player.
So now we can run Terraform
apply. And well, spins up. We'll quickly take
a look at the code and what's actually
happening. I thought to be honest, it's really,
really easy. Well,
easy is a bold word, but it really
is.
From here we need an EquinixMatter project ID
to get this. Just go to the console
and this massive UUID
that you have after projects is your project
ID.
You can also get this from project settings
where you can copy it
like so.
We paste this in
and before I had this, let me change
one more thing.
So
and variables,
we have the metros that we're going to
deploy to and I'm gonna make this a
bit bigger. This is smaller because I was
on my laptop earlier. Here we go.
This is our metros and you can see
here I'm going to deploy it to D
E which is Dallas and AM which is
Amsterdam. And I'm actually gonna turn off
Amsterdam
for now
Because I wanna see this perform
not slowly, but I wanna see the latency
kind of well from The UK to Dallas,
which is a bit more than from The
UK to Amsterdam. And then we'll deploy that
second Metro. The BGP advertisement will then start
written or traffic and we'll get faster fairway
on platform,
which is the goal for today's session.
So we can hit return on this ID.
TerraForm is gonna go bloop bloop bloop.
Oh, it's in changes rather than no. It's
okay. It's ads. I
know it's
let's run that again, but now that I've
saved the change. Hopefully, we don't get
alright.
This is in a currently broken state. So
that's gonna be absolutely perfect, doesn't it? Let's
run a terraform refresh.
Really,
did not clean this up at some point.
I'm gonna try again.
I'm just gonna let it go. This may
fail. We're gonna find out.
So what happened is I think before I
had COVID last week, so I was off
all week, which is why the stream moved
to today instead of last week. But I
think during my testing, I've left up, realized
that while I was sick, went to the
Equities Federal Council, shut down all the instances,
and now we're in this position that we
see today.
But I don't think that's a big deal
because we can see that we are getting
the Dallas instance spun up and hopefully TerraForm
will just clean up the state fail for
their missing resources.
Well, that spins up. It does take around
one to two minutes.
We can see what this code does.
Now
this is really standard terraform
that grabs the reserved IP address from the
Equinix middle API.
We're just doing a little bit of juggling
with the values so that we can get
a global IP and a global IP with
the cider.
This is needed for some configuration aspects, not
important right now.
We have the IP attachment which we do
for each device and each metro
and then we build our cloud and a
configuration.
So let's see. This bit
here
is already provided for you by Fermion. This
is what
all
of the cloud providers use.
However, you'll see that I've kind of thrown
in this bootstrap component
which just sets up all the stuff that
we need
for this platform to run with BGP
integrated.
And that just means installing and configuring Bert
on the on the Linux hosts so that
we can get that BGP advertisement.
Nothing else in here is particularly
different from any other provider. This is just
standard fair mail platform Terraform.
The bet that we've added to make this
different is to set up BGP script.
Now we just make sure we have JQ
installed because we are doing a little bit
of JSON juggling and the fact that we
pulled down the Equinix MERL metadata
which is a JSON blob that our Terraform
throws into it for us.
We sleep because sometimes this metadata isn't there
until the BGP is turned on for the
device, which is why we then repeat
until we have access to a key called
BGP neighbors.
Once we have the BGP neighbor information, it
means that we can configure BART and even
add the BGP
address
to the loopback device on the host.
Now if you're not familiar with Linux and
Linux networking stuff, don't worry about it. We're
just really making sure that this IP address
will always route to one of our Linux
machines and that that machine can actually respond
for the IP address.
We configure some default routing for the BGP
peers
and then we install BERD. Now again,
I'm not really doing anything manually here. The
team Equinix metal formerly packet host, which is
why this is packet
host repository
wrote a
Python script
published as network helpers and as long as
you can just kind of pep the install
and then run configure,
it will actually speak to the Equinix metal
API, get all the peer information,
configure the
well, just configure the entire bird
instance so that you don't need to do
anything. And in fact, the only thing we
do do is just restart it,
which is nice.
From there, I did have to modify the
standard fermion platform nomad jobs.
So you'll see here, I am waiting for
the file provisioner,
which throws all of the
nomad stuff,
haplo,
family on platform,
bundle,
blah onto the root directory. And once we
have that, we're actually patching it. So
family on platform isn't really designed
to
lessen
on like multiple
not multiple IP addresses, but you know,
each Linux machine has its IPv4
address and then the global IP address is
different from it. And we actually want some
stuff to listen on the machines IPv4
and not the global IPv4.
So we have to modify the traffic instance,
which is a proxy set in front of
all of the fair mail platform components
and just say, hey, actually, we have the
domain that we're configuring on a host level,
but also we need to add on
our BGP IP address to.
Yeah, that kind of makes sense.
Yeah. So
instead of just saying, hey, listen on this,
we need to add in the HIPAA host
and we do the same for bundle actually,
which is done here. Let me see here.
And this is just so that we can
when you're creating the
spin applications deployed to the platform,
you could use the BGP
address and host name, and it doesn't matter
which one you hit. But if you want
to get to the hyper UI,
then you you really wanna have control over
that. So we're specifically saying I wanna be
able to request this on the local IPP
for address.
And we do the same for bundle and
that's it. That's the only two modifications that
had to be made to the entire stack,
which is just as time for this to
pop over here and hopefully be healthy.
Well, let's go back to our read me.
We're not fussed about the TLS configuration or
anything like that right now.
What I actually want
is
did they not put this in the read
me?
No big deal. What we actually want is
the Hepco password.
So we can run Terraform
output,
which will spit out
all that stuff.
But what we want to do is request
a specific value,
which is our heppo
admin
password
dot
value.
No. We can do that with JQ. That
pulls out a JSON blob.
This is then JQ
value and we wanna raw or put quotes
though.
Let's try again.
What does that give me? Oh, it just
gives me a password. Never mind.
Let's copy this. And
then we can come up here and
copy the hippo address.
So Please work.
Maybe it's not ready yet.
Alright. When in doubt, we do debugging. So
the other thing that we have access to
is the SSH private key.
So let's do Terraform,
I put private key
and write this to prev
and then we open prev.
Make sure we only have the private key.
Change the permissions
on it to be four hundred.
And then we want to get to the
IP address of the machine. And then the
fastest way to get that is probably
go to here and see manage servers. This
is the IP address for the machine and
not the BGP address.
And we can connect to the instance assuming
well,
all good.
And then tail
bar log
clouds
and output.
So you can see it's looping
because it's not got the BGP information.
And I don't know why.
Let's take a look at our host.
Go to BGP.
Actually looks good.
Let's run this manually and see what the
problem is.
Okay.
Let's see.
Interesting.
This resource here is our BGP session
for the machine.
And I'm going to assume that maybe it
wasn't added, although it does appear to be
added.
Oh, I think that's it because I have
everything in such a weird state.
Damn myself.
When in doubt,
we're on a terraform destroyer.
And a tear form
apply.
That does mean that we will have to
wait approximately a minute and half to two
minutes for this machine to come up.
Oh, no.
What have I broken now?
I really hate having the debug stuff live.
I think my project's not found.
Oh, wait. What's this?
Schedule maintenance. Yeah. That's not gonna bother me.
Right?
Well, my project ID ends on 132.
Oh, this is not the project it's using.
What was I pasting?
I have no idea.
It's always me though, isn't it? Alright, so
that's just gonna take a minute or two
now.
And what I'll do is as soon as
this is spun up,
as we'll just go straight into that HEPL
UI,
deploy our spin application, and then we'll quickly
add that second one to the Amsterdam region
where we'll see the latency drop by
hopefully around three hundred milliseconds.
Good evening.
Welcome to the stream.
So we can see the failed provisioner is
now running. This is the one that puts
Fermion
installer no more jobs on to the machine.
All that fun stuff.
Let's grab
IP address here
BSSH.
And we'll tail
a cloud and an output
where we can see currently it's on the
g q install step,
which is good.
It's now trying to get the metadata. It's
already got it and now it's proceeding to
provision correctly.
No rustle.
No
worry rules. Hopefully, no more breaks.
So recovering from the COVID.
Be nice. Be gentle.
Happy testing negative for four days. That's Friday.
Three days.
I'm still tired.
I'm very tired.
Alright. We're almost there. Now it's all a
nomad
console
vault.
These are all the components used to give
us a fair mail platform.
Bundle,
which is where it distributes and shares or
spin applications.
Hepoo which is the kind of orchestrator component.
Nomad which runs all of our jobs.
Sweet. This is looking pretty good. So I'm
gonna pop back off and we're gonna do
a terraform output.
We want the hippo admin password.
We also want
the URL,
which is here.
So
I wish the Terraformer could go to the
BGP one, but I want you to bypass
it and just go directly to this machine
because Bert may still be advertiser may not
have actually advertised the address yet. But you
can see that we did get the thing.
So now we can grab the password
and we can do admin
password.
Perfect. Now we have a platform where we
could deploy an application,
but we're not gonna do it this way.
We'll do it from the CLI.
So we need a new tab
I'll approve this.
And we need
a spin application.
Where did I put my spin application?
This is what happens when you disappear.
Listen demo.
Alright.
So now we can do a spin log
in and we provide a URL,
which is HTTPS,
hippo.
Password.
Let's copy this.
Like so.
Then to log and suspend application,
Russell's like, woah, ASP dot NET Core.
Yeah. Hippo is a
days lab project, which I believe is mostly
dot net.
So we're not gonna send them a gap
because we haven't configured it as to do
any gap application
client nonsense. We're going to use a new
password for we see the heppool username admin.
The password is that one that I've now
lost all access to. So let's scroll back
up.
Like, so
the bundle URL
is the same IP address that we use
for the hyper URL, but with bundle start.
So that's 1477535151
and it does need v one on the
end.
And there's no authentication
and now we're logged in to our bare
main platform.
In fact, you can just spend deploy.
Why?
Not trusted.
Can I skip that?
Oh, wait. Why is that HTTP?
Try again.
I wonder if it's supposed to be HTTP
and I've got myself into some weird mesh
mesh mode.
Yeah. So it's bit not.
I'm just going to buy by it, bypass
it.
Oh, yeah. Because why would it be HTTPS
because I'm using a slip. We're not using
a real domain name.
Alright. It should
endo
one four seven
five. Should really just be copying this from
now on, but hopefully it's the last time.
Spin,
play.
What did I get wrong?
Let's see what happens if we curl this.
404.
That happens if our patch doesn't work.
I
am
never going to do a demo after being
elegant.
Let's jump onto this machine.
We can run nomad status.
Bundle is running.
We'll check our logs to see if there
were any errors.
Oh, it looks perfect.
We can even
use this
to see console.
Yeah. Bundle's running.
But it's not got both the hosts.
So
our patch job.
So if you've ever seen dot reg dot
reject fails before, this is what happens when
a patch doesn't work.
So we're gonna do it normally. We're gonna
do it manually.
Manually, normally. Yeah.
And why it didn't work? I have no
idea. I'm gonna fix that later.
Let's just copy it from here.
Get rid of you.
And we don't need to double
dollar sign. That's just to get past the
terraform interpolation.
But that looks good now.
And the last thing we need to do
comes from
comes from the Fermion installer where we have
to actually tell it to run the job.
And in order for this, this is all
getting very complicated now and you shouldn't have
to worry about this. But I feel like
I'm committed now.
If we go to var
var log cloud and output,
scroll to the bottom.
We need to copy this,
export them to the environment,
goes to the Fermion installer,
grab the share Terraform
VM assets,
run servers and then here there's a nomad
command
to run bundle.
Like so.
So we need to run this to tell
to recreate the bundle job.
And I'm in the job directory. So let's
just pop up.
Oh, it's looking for that list encrypt.
We can just set that to false.
Now restarting our bundle job,
which is done.
Alright.
Thank you for bearing with me.
My curl command is on this tab.
And now
we get a four zero four.
So that was gonna be it.
Let's find.
Let's Let's see what we see
and our services because we wanna see
yeah.
So anything on bendle.
Should resolve to the bendle server.
Maybe that 404 and the v one is
fine. Maybe this Maybe that's a prefix.
Not entirely sure.
Let's just be bold.
Yeah. Russell only one of the patches failed.
So Russell was asking there's two changes.
Your setup script, you only made one in
the thing
on the terminal.
And because it was only a thought a
wrench and dot rejection for the bundle patch.
I'm not sure why this failed
to patch.
Normally happens if you get spaces and tabs
wrong, but all these dots here to suggest
I'm using spaces which is fine.
I will fix that.
Something silly but I only had to apply
the one. But as you can see now,
it did deploy.
We can call our application and we get
hello fermion. This is good.
We could
benchmark this if we want.
I don't have drill installed.
Doesn't matter.
Yeah.
Throwing me for six.
If you refresh console,
let's use our application here, the random UUID.
If we pop this out, go to here,
change the path so it's not apt new.
We now have our demo application.
So we're now deploying to the fermion platform.
We could run an MTR.
Why have I not got any cool commands?
This is just also cool commands.
MTRs
like a tracer drill is a HTTP benchmarking
tool.
We'll give them just a wee second.
So we can run drill
our IP address.
Maybe I was wrong. If you're on drill
again.
Oh, you need to fail, don't you?
I've forgotten how to drill rust
drill. It should be.
That's a bit more complicated than I was
hoping for.
It should be a request latency.
Test
my
I don't test my latency.
I have forgotten how to computer.
This should be
latency test.
Solar runs. I don't know if I trust
you.
I want to test my ping.
Oh, whatever.
Let's see.
Russell, how would you test the speed of
an h two p request? Come on. Tell
me.
HTTP
test
speed response.
I mean, how hard can this be?
Alright. Test. Cool. Tested from Europe.
London's close enough.
Well, that does its thing. What is m
t r,
the BGP address?
So the BGP address is from our terraform
output.
This one here.
If I go ahead to MGR.
No. MGR host name.
Oh, why am I gonna protocol on there?
Oh, I hit me again.
MTR requires to do.
Finally,
I swear I'm good at this stuff. Let's
let them try running.
Because you hear the latency for our from
London to our application,
three hundred milliseconds. I'm gonna let the MTR
finish before I lose my mind.
We're going to add that second region
very, very quickly.
And I'll need the project ID.
And yes.
Cool.
So we've seen the latency from London to
Dallas at three hundred milliseconds. Our MTR is
working on it.
We never actually tested the BGP route, did
we?
Maybe this is going to go into the
great unknown.
That if we copy
this.
No.
This
demo.
There's our application.
Yeah. That's the BGP one. Nice.
Cool.
So I don't know why the MTR is
taking so long actually.
Normally that'd be showing us the route.
Let register the IP address this time.
The reason it failed was I didn't do
it the first time. That's the other thing.
Now our second instance is now up, which
is good.
What we can do, which is the regional
IP output here to go on to Amsterdam.
We can follow the progress of that deploy.
It's working on it.
MTR is working on it.
The Carl's fine.
Things are happening
not necessarily all going well. Let's see.
So once the Nomad jobs for the Amsterdam
One deployed, when I do a curl on
an MTR, it should rip to the Amsterdam
instance instead of the Dallas instance. We should
see a latency, hopefully no more than about
fifty milliseconds.
And this was supposed to be a twenty
minute stream and we're forty minutes in, but
you know sometimes shit happens.
As Russell knows all too well.
Alright. Bundles on its way.
No HEPL.
What's going over that MTR?
It's usually super quick.
Alright.
Almost there.
Now I do need to log in and
deploy the application to this instance.
Now the BGP advertisement will be working.
And so we probably see a photo for
now if we were to curl.
Nope.
So you can see here,
we got hold fermion and there we got
a four zero four. So you still have
to deploy your application
and that means you have to log in
to your application.
And for each instance,
we can drop it first from terraform
terraform.
Output.
We want that regional IP again
where we can log in
.sslip.i0
to
admin. We need the password.
No. Don't get the course this time.
We need the bundle URL.
14540.
No.
754012SSlipIOB1.
I wonder where that's been login goes. Can
I change that?
No idea.
Like not to mess it up this time.
Bundle.
Empty hours gone. Don't know what's happening. Let's
get rid of it.
When that's deploy finishes, we'll do the Carl.
Hopefully it's not $4.00 4.
Although the bundle configuration is not gonna work
on this machine either, is it?
And I just use the BGP address.
We'll get there.
Any minute now.
Two
admin
password.
Bindle,
not BGP.
We want this.
Course that doesn't work.
And I'm gonna type this and I'm gonna
have to go into that patch again, aren't
I? And it's gonna feel
five.
Resource not found.
Easy job.
We have a rejected fail.
End of up normad.
Copy.
Improve the extra
quote dollar thing.
Words.
Cat bar log cloud in it.
Get all of this.
Go back to here.
I closed it.
This one.
Change the list of crypt to false.
Course, that's not gonna work.
Good to uninstall my computer. Just never fit
on it. I think it's time for it
to go away.
So
this panel will work.
The job will be replaced.
It has been replaced.
Do a deploy.
Twenty minutes stream, my ass. Anyway.
Just sort of giggles
or on the pseudo mtr.
Don't know why those are
just therapeutic.
It's during that Carl command back.
And we get hello from you.
The MTR is probably not gonna ever work.
So we're gonna go back to this wonderful
random website that we found.
And I wonder if I can just refresh
the page.
No.
Run now.
Now let's see if it's any faster.
Give it up an empty hour.
Well, this should not be a fast test,
a slow test.
So now it's a hundred milliseconds instead of
three hundred. I should expect it to be
faster,
but I
am not going to try and push
this hodgepodge of automation any further because clearly
the odds against anything working today.
So what is the take home from today's
session?
Things go wrong,
granted.
Firming on platform is open source. Right? There's
nothing particularly special
about it. It uses Nomad,
Vault,
and Console
as your building blocks for a
distributed
orchestration system against multiple hosts. I took the
easy approach today and deployed unique ones to
each metro. Of course, there are more advanced
architecture there. Right? Nomads can scale horizontally.
We could have used the same Nomad cluster
on multiple machines. However, that's a session for
another day.
Once we have that substrate to build our
platform, we're deploying Hippo and Bundle from data
slabs,
which allows us to run web assembly applications.
And we also get that nice Hippo UI
where you can see I could log in.
I could see my applications, it gave me
the URL, it gave me the logs, it
gave me the environment details,
all the components that you've come to know
and love with Fermion Cloud.
But we ran it ourselves.
And using Equinix medal, we were able to
be able to distribute this geographically.
I only use two metros,
Dallas in The US and Amsterdam in Europe,
but you could do that to wherever your
customers are to deliver them via BGP written
low latency applications.
And that all coming together, I think is
really cool. Now clearly the automation needs a
little bit of work. I hope that by
me debugging this on the go.
You cannot understand a little bit more about
what was actually happening. But of course as
always, if you have any questions or you
wanna do something slightly bespoke, just jump straight
into the comment section.
Ask away. I'll do my best to ask
this.
What's Russell's last comment before I sign off
for today?
If you make changes on the fly, does
it become get ignore ops?
This is why I've been doing more pre
recorded video lately because then you never see
my mistakes,
but then it's nice to have fun and
say hello to y'all while I do this.
So go check out family on platform, Check
out the pull request if you wanna play
it with an equest metal. However, there are
there is TerraForm code to deploy to AWS,
GCP, SQL cloud, and many others. So go
check it out. Thank you all for joining
me today. Thank you for persisting with me
if you're still here, I'll see you all
on the next session.
Have a great day.